hi I'm Terry Crews and I'm gonna go
undercover on the Internet
this is actually me oh we gotta get real
it's about to get real up in hell
first up Cora what's the character Terry
in Brooklyn nine-nine intentionally
named after Terry Crews yes
I had three pilots that I was looking at
and Dan Gore and Mike Shore called me up
and they said hey Terry we heard you're
looking at other pilots if you take
another pilot you're gonna feel horrible
because your name is gonna be on
somebody else and I went you bastards
you bastards
of course I'll do it and that's how
Terry got on for tonight not if I wanted
to get a body like Terry Crews or my
culture my man Luke Cage realistically
what would I have to do and how often
would I have to work out every day you
have to start small and think big it
takes a long time it's like asking if I
want to be a doctor you know what do I
have to read to be a doctor
well you gotta go to school a long time
and buy in about eight years you'll be a
document post-it ready apparently you
can play the flute - was that really him
playing it on that rap battle show yes I
am a flautist I played a flute let me
tell you something it's the best
instrument ever people that wear that's
a purely instrument no it's not the
baddest cat chef got flu at all I'm
trying to tell you it's a badass
instrument next the job military crews
has never actually been bald he just
shaved his head every morning because
now y'all do
oh yeah I know I'm sorry I shave every
morning I have a head full of hair but
if you saw me with it you freaked out
it's too weird even my wife goes ah
shave your head yeah
where can I lay my eyeballs on some of
Terry's art one day when I get this on
I'm actually going to take a year off
and just do heart and just paint draw
and hold it and I'm gonna have a show
that is coming very very soon you too
whoa get more real we just keep going
well Terry Crews act for Old Spice again
please maybe you should call him call
him up let him know you want power back
huh huh let them know let him see Oh
mystery like yogurt I love yogurt they
added it to the show they put it on the
show because they saw me eating you
where all the time on Brooklyn nine-nine
weightlifting competition Dwayne Johnson
vs Terry Crews anyone Wow what you all
have to understand there is no versus
when it comes to me and Dwayne Johnson
Dwayne is my brother I can't wait for us
to do something together it'll always be
us together Danny no versus and is it
cuz it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense we cancel each other out
it's like Oh Instagram it's actually me
you mentioned that you've intermittently
fast until 2 p.m. every day but you work
out early in the morning how do you
repair your muscles after working out
without consuming protein asking for a
friend
I don't let them repair I hurt these
muscles I bagged them up
now I would never ever recommend this
for a 20 year old but I'm 50 years old
what you have to do always always is
listen to your own body follow your own
rules and discover what works for you
and that is how I do my workout and it's
still here going anywhere that you play
for the Packers yeah I did but right
before the season started I got cut two
days later I was picked up by the San
Diego Chargers and I was so happy in San
Diego it's not cold so that was the end
of my cheesehead experience up in
Wisconsin did you do this or did
somebody scan your head for something I
don't know where it came from but man
that's good
they got me and somewhere they got me we
do scans for movies and different things
and sometimes people leak these things I
did a picture for white chicks with no
clothes on and
me holding a basketball in my private
and they thought oh that's way too much
let's not use it you know what happened
somebody from the show put that picture
on the internet and it's there forever
I've had people walk up to me with a
picture of me holding a basketball in my
crotch and say sign it and I'm like damn
it damn you Internet he can do a lot but
can he speak French oui oui no Monsieur
I am dB Oh Terry Cruz was born in Flint
Michigan to Patricia and Terry crew
senior he earned an art excellence
scholarship to attend Western Michigan
University and also earned a full ride
athletic scholarship to play football
Cruz was an all-conference defensive end
I had an art scholarship to go to
Western Michigan University it was very
very small I could not pay the rest of
my schooling on art so what I had to do
was walk on to the football team and I
eventually earned a full ride
scholarship and I was one of the players
that was drafted into the pros when I
left the school the only fact that they
don't have right here is that I am NOT a
junior Terry Crews and my dad but I have
a middle name I am Terry Allen Cruz so
that technically does not make me a
junior so that's the straighten that all
out Wikipedia is up next
his breakout role came in Friday after
next starring Ice Cube from whom crews
have previously worked I'm on set as a
bodyguard they like to sex it up I was
never a bodyguard not about a guy I was
born set security I had a flashlight I
had my lunch right next to me and I had
a little polo shirt that had cash
security on it and then we're like hey
man get these extras out of here at all
the hey y'all y'all can't stand I was on
set security on next Friday and ended up
in right after next Twitter
hey Terry Crews do you have a new design
of gaming cheer in the works cause if
you do then shut up and take my money I
love this mean this is one of my
favorite meal I do have a new collection
coming out it's not specifically a
gaming chair but if you said it and you
playing the game does he even care what
serene psycho you got a gaming chair
coming to you and 2019 from Terry Crews
next
how did Muse get [ __ ] Terry Crews to
be in their music videos
Muse approached me about being in his
music video and I was like yeah you know
what y'all didn't see that coming
and that that's what makes it so
satisfying is because no one expected it
I love just popping up out of your
cereal box yeah alright guys I hope you
got your answers it was actually me
Terry Crews live life to the fullest do
your thing I love you all I'm out drink
you